let's talk next about a new poll from
cbs
news that really highlights
the degree to which we're in serious
trouble in this country
because of the things that people
believe disproportionately right-wingers
disproportionately republicans
disproportionately trumpets now some
will write in and say
you know david uh uh you are over
exaggerating the degree to which these
problems are among the american right
and i would say
no i'm not the data actually tells us
that that's
exactly the case so let's take a look at
um at the poll cbs
news still more to learn about january
6th most americans say
some of the data here is concerning and
some is not we'll look at some of the
questions
when it comes to the january 6th attack
on the capital
72 percent of americans say there is
more to learn
and 28 percent say we know all there is
to know
this is one of those questions where in
principle
there's nothing concerning here it was
a complex event in the sense that it
involved a lot of moving parts
it was multifaceted in that it was
donald trump and republicans and
rightwing media and others
fomenting the idea that the election was
stolen and i would agree
there is still more to learn the problem
is a lot of the people who say there's
still more to learn
what they mean by that is even at the
top level
that this was violent right-wingers
inspired by
republicans with the lie that the
election was stolen which it wasn't
that's not even something that they
would accept so this
is actually quite concerning
among republicans when they were asked
about the actions of those who forced
their way into the capital
the number of republicans that strongly
disapprove of the riots
has declined by 12 points in other words
more people uh now at least to some
degree
approve of what took place on january
6th and most of that is
in somewhat approved there's an increase
in people that disapprove but only
somewhat
and so the point here is the strong
republican opposition
condemnation of what happened on january
6 has declined 12 points
since january what how would you
describe what happened at the capitol
um 55
of trump voters describe what happened
at the capitol
as a defense of freedom
and 51 of trumpists describe what
happened at the capitol
as patriotism this is
absolutely unconscionable now
if you're looking at the graphic 20 of
trump
voters call what happened on the sixth
an insurrection
i'm actually surprised that even 20 of
them are willing to call it that
this is the type of now i'm not saying
these people are nazis that's not what
i'm saying
what i am saying though is that this
level of cognitive dissonance
with what took place on that day is the
type of thing
that created a vacuum in which hitler
was able to seize power in 1930s germany
i'm not saying anyone is hitler i'm not
saying anyone is a nazi
but this is the type of thing where when
you see people this disconnected 55
percent of trump voters say
those riots that violent insurrectious
coup attempt
that was a defense of freedom that's
really really dangerous stuff and in
particular it was a riot fomented
uh by the then sitting president um
66 percent of all respondents say that
u.s democracy today is threatened and 34
say it is secure this is a really
complicated
um question and unfortunately it's like
i don't even know that these polls give
us what we need to know because
there are people on the left who believe
democracy is threatened
because trump and republicans try to
overturn the overturn the results of the
election
there are people on the right who think
that democracy is threatened
because they believe that joe biden
didn't really win and is somehow
now the president so even a simple
question like democracy is threatened
today
the answer doesn't really tell us much
because the reasons why people say yes
very dramatically the bottom line is
this was an attempt to overturn the
election results based on the lie that
it was stolen
that riotous insurrection was fomented
by the then
sitting president it was uh
uh it was bad enough how the right
reacted at the time
but six months later they are sort of
you could call it a revisionist history
you could call it a group delusion
whatever you call it the percentage of
republicans who don't think it was that
serious has gone up in the five months
since six months since it took place
and the percentage of republicans and
trump voters who say it was a positive
act
to defend freedom has gone up
dramatically so what is the takeaway
the takeaway continues to be number one
i don't know how we fix this
i i just have i'm out of ideas guys
number two
the extremist faction of the republican
party
is the dominant wing if you are
a vile republican in most ways
like liz cheney is but you think guys
this election stuff makes us look stupid
you are now apparently in the minority
in the republican party at least as far
as they're willing to admit
publicly and then final takeaway
joe manchin and kirsten cinema two
democratic senators
who insist that we want to find common
ground with republicans
we want to work together we need to find
compromise that is between what
democrats and republicans want
these are the people that you were
trying to do that with the people 55
percent who say
the riots were a defense of freedom only
20
of whom are willing to say it was an
attempted insurrection
joe manchin and kirsten cinema how
exactly do you find common ground with
those people it's a genuine question
we're really really in trouble
um i want to remind you the david pakman
show is not in trouble we are actually
on the precipice of our 16th anniversary
at the completion of monday august 16th
it will be
our 16th anniversary and so on the 16th
16th for 16 it's very 16 related
we're going to do a membership special
if you've been thinking of signing up
we're primarily funded by our viewers
and listeners like you
through the membership program monday
august 16th we'll be doing a big one day
membership special i hope that you will
get on my newsletter at davidpakman.com
and then monday the 16th you'll get a
fantastic email
telling you how to take advantage of
this
criminally low membership discount
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company
best known for their delicious mushroom
coffee
four sigmatics mushroom coffee is
organic
fair trade single origin arabica coffee
with both lion's mane and chaga
mushrooms chaga mushrooms have actually
been shown to have potential in
supporting the immune system
in peer-reviewed studies i've been
drinking four
sigmatic coffee a lot lately it actually
doesn't taste anything like mushrooms it
just tastes like
any delicious coffee but it's really
easy on my stomach
doesn't give me any jittery feeling or a
midday crash
and they have over 20 000 five star
reviews and best of all if you don't
love it
you'll get 100 percent of your money
back because
they stand behind their product you've
got nothing to lose by giving it a try
four sigmatic is giving my audience up
to forty percent
off and free shipping when you go to
four sigmatic dot com slash pacman
the link is right underneath this video